Ancient and modern,...
...rich and poor,...
...fascinating and entertaining,...
...practical and elegant,...
...Lima is a city of contrasts.
Almost a third of all Peruvians...
...call this sprawling metropolis home,...
...and they live in everything from modern high-rise condos...
...to humble hilltop shacks.
The painted facades burst with color in summer,…
...but this image is paled by the fog that rises...
...from the Pacific Ocean in winter.
In this ever-changing city, you can find a new surprise...
...at every turn.
All you have to do is prepare your senses.
Along the boulevards of central Lima,...
...you'll be immersed in the sounds of chaotic traffic,...
...while quiet benches await in coastal parks.
Everywhere you go in Lima,...
...you can feel the hot desert sun warm your skin,...